really interested by the conversations
you all have any because there are so
many in fact here's what I want you to
do just for a second because you've been
able to look at the answers of the
people nearby you can you just if you're
at the front of the room holding your
book backwards and if you're at the back
of the room hallo you every one holiday
but I just want you to all look around
each other's books and how different hot
of the velocity sorry the speed graph is
the one I'm interested in okay I don't
know I don't know if I see a single
graph that is the same even though we're
all looking at the same distance time
graph this is this is democracy okay you
can put your books now all right let's
have a think about how we can put this
together okay now what I'm going to do
is an approach that you might remember
from when we looked at just random
graphs and tried to find out derivatives
right let's have a think again about
some important points that are here and
if you've done yours like mine and put
your speed time graph directly below
your height time graph you can get out a
ruler and just do it vertically and no
doubt some interesting is for example
this is the first interesting point that
we all observed the stationary point
right that's the top of his journey we
called a stationary point because where
is canon man going what direction is he
moving at that instant in time he's not
going anywhere this speed is zero so
when I look at my speed graph if I want
the speed to be zero I'm going to zoom
in your hands here we go I enjoy this
all the way down and I encourage you to
do the same right I've got a vertical
line there representing it's the same
time coordinate right same time
coordinate time whatever I don't know
one and a half seconds or something I
don't even know what it is right but
importantly the speed of this infinite
time is going to be zero the speed is
going to be zero at that instant is the
speed ever zero at any other time
massive
at the end I suppose Elance doesn't like
here he lands so I didn't draw the rest
I guess I could have drawn the rest of
the ground hey did anyone else
I just stopped time stops existing kind
of man just disappeared or for some of
you just appeared and disappeared arena
so I if a cannon man is not flying
through the air does he even exist
anyway so that's what's happening so
from that point on time is also sorry
speeds also zero where's my orange Hugo
but apart from that he's always in
motion
do you agree he is always moving so his
speed every other time is going to be
positive you okay with that rested you
have a thought or a question yeah let's
come to that so the beginning is a point
of contention for a lot of you right
some of you have it here some of you
have it here so you have it here all
different kinds of shapes right let's
think about what is happening to can
emit at the instant when you press play
is he moving as soon as you press play
he is right because he's been shot out
of a cannon presumably there's no
countdown anything like that
no three two one soon as you hit play
off he goes right so that means that
speed is not zero at that point in time
that would mean he's not going anywhere
speed is gonna be some kind of positive
value now admittedly we do not have any
scale on this so whether it's higher
whether it's lower does not matter too
much but I'm going to put him somewhere
up here because as soon as he starts
going what happens to his speed it slows
down why is that I drew it up in green
for you yeah the instant he starts
flying gravity is trying to slow him
down by the way gravity is already doing
that when he's in the cannon right
what's stopping him from going like he's
in the cannon right now he's sitting
there why isn't he dropping when he's in
the cannon he's on the ground in other
words the ground
the cannon is exerting a force upward so
that's why you all are not moving
anywhere right it's actually the
electromagnetic force of the carpet
that's exerting a force upward on your
feet you're not going anywhere it's
exactly countering gravity which is why
not going anywhere
make sense but once he's moving
gravity's like aha I can do stuff now
right so he starts actually accelerating
downwards so this is gonna start
dropping right do you agree now just for
a second look up for a minute
I need something to cover this yes or do
you just have a look at that shape there
just have a look at it right you try and
flex your calculus brain now which you
sort of been doing but informally what
is that shape look like that shape looks
like a parabola right which is not a
coincidence by the way so if you had a
shape like this a parabola what would
you guess it's equation might look
something like this is a parabola right
so there's gonna be an x squared it's a
quadratic very good now it's a parabola
right now by the way it's a it's facing
downwards right it's concave down right
so instead of having x squared which is
concave up it would be something like
minus x squared and then there'll be
some other terms to get it into the
right position all that kind of thing
okay now if we took this object this guy
here let's think about this with all the
calculus stuff you develop if you
differentiated this what would you get
can you describe this to me geometric we
know this is a straight line can you
tell me is it going up is it going down
it's going down right it's a straight
line going down now why should a
derivative connect this to this right
well speed is nothing but the change in
height compared to the change in time
that's what it is I should point out
it's it's just the positive value seven
trucks map to values there it's all the
positive side but this idea of oh I know
what this shape is it's a parabola right
that's what all objects under gravity do
so therefore I should have not a curvy
line but a straight line connecting me
to this spot here where you suddenly
stop at the top does that make sense
have a look at your graph think about
what you've got and how different that
is right this is not this is not stuff
that we did in abstract so it's like oh
I just know how to move this algebra
around it tells you how to interpret a
physical situation okay so we've gotten
so far from launch
to the top of Ken Ahmed's flight path
right what happens after that we're wait
before before the passion this is I'm
only at the top here right Gary what do
you see it sort of goes up a bit right
now hold on a second look you've got a
parabola here right it's still look at
this instant in time here it's still a
parabola right so when you differentiate
this what would you expect to get still
a straight line something like that
okay with that why have I stopped
because the parachute opens okay now you
all described this to me as a straight
line that would mean it's equation is
something like you know - I don't know
like 1/2 X or something like that it's
quite gentle and then it's going to have
some y-intercept up here so I don't know
what that is but what happens when you
differentiate that you just get a
constant in other words when you graph a
constant you get a not just a straight
line because this is a straight line you
get a horizontal line right so you're
getting something like that right how's
that make sense yeah now since we
decided to ask this question when I get
to the end here what happens he's landed
what happens to his speed
it drops does it like sort of take a
second to drop down it doesn't in fact
it's already there at that instant and
then he's not moving right because it's
on the ground so we've got this kind of
break that happens here right which is a
bit weird but that's just what he's
doing this thing here right the
connection between these two we'll talk
about this in more detail later but if
you remember when we talked about
continuity right it's kind of like I'm
not I'm not in the movie
or I'm between one of the other hold on
a second can you say that last bit again
and I want Shore to listen carefully cuz
I listen really carefully this language
obviously really matters here can you
say it again I just make sure I really
understand what you're saying yeah it's
okay you're talking about this point
here yeah yep yep so you're talking
about the fact that at this point here
surely it should take some time to slow
him down is that what you mean is there
not an immediate changes made or are you
saying I've got an immediate changed me
so oh I think I said you man yep yes yes
yes I think you're right actually so
I've got an issue here right I've got a
break here for when he hits the ground
but in fact I think you're correct in
saying that there's a gradient change
here to here right because in fact and
that's the whole point cuz otherwise
he'd hit splat on the ground what should
I do to fix this graph up if this graph
has a problem you're saying wait what do
you mean by down downwards like as in
like that
so I'm getting a few idea Matt can you
explain what you mean by disconnected
okay so let's shift this whole thing
let's get this on a different color here
so we're saying something like well
should we house it has that is that okay
I just I just made that that height up
okay okay I do have a question shouldn't
it still be connected that's a good
question
we've just a few of you are saying it
should be disconnected and well I've got
two versions of the graph here right
which one is a more accurate
representation of what's happening what
do you think you should neither other I
don't like option A or B none of the
above is he let's think about this now I
did ask you to close your laptop's
unfortunately but think about what
perish what kinda man is doing right
does he does he slow down during this
section here does he slowed down I think
let me repay what you just said tacky
when he opens the parachute his speed
until he hits the ground is the same
which is why hopefully as you tried it
out right some of you might have started
with a curved line here and then you hit
play and he like wait that's not what
Kahneman is doing and then you fixed it
up and you're like okay a straight line
here a straight line so if you've got a
straight line here it's derivative its
speed in this case it's going to be
constant say it again
huh shouldn't this be be different
because the gravity is affected by
height
here's where I'm going to suggest to you
at this point right all models this is a
model of what's going on right all
models are lies but some some lies are
useful so in this case you're right I
mean if if kena man was like up in the
upper atmosphere right that's going to
have a different effect on gravity
because gravity is of is inversely
proportional to the square of the
distance yes no sure sure okay
no one who's studying physics here is
correcting me the engineer the back the
room is not correct Amina
so you're correct however for the
purposes of this very simplified model
in fact for our purposes it does not
change at least it not in a way that we
can measure because we're just
eyeballing it anyway okay so I think the
Zaku is correct there is actually a
slowdown you can see it there in the
gradient what is this it's a measure of
the grading of this thing but I'm just
taking the positive part okay I should
fix this up let's see I don't know put
that there and that's pretty different
to what everyone had including me the
first time when I drew it are you happy
with that